TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
CONGRESS IS TRYING TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT ON DACA, THAT IS
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S PROGRAM THAT
GAVE MINORS A FREE TICKET TO THE
UNITED STATES.
HOW DARE HE SAY SOMETHING LIKE
THAT?
SO FROM HOLLYWOOD TO SILICON
VALLEY TO MSNBC, A NEW CONSENSUS
HAS FORMED WHICH THE REST OF US
ARE REQUIRED TO BELIEVE.
GET A PEN.
IT'S THIS.
EVERY OTHER COUNTRY IS GREAT
ESPECIALLY THE POOR AND
UNIFORMLY MORE IMPRESSIVE THAN
YOU ARE, EVERY ONE OF THEM.
THEY FIGHT MORE WARS, PAY MORE
TAXES AND START MORE COMPANIES
THAN YOUR KIDS EVER WILL.
SO SHUT UP WITH YOUR DOUBTS OR
THE QUESTION IS, DO THEY REALLY
BELIEVE THAT?
DO THEY REALLY THINK THAT ALL
STANDARDS ARE ARBITRARY AND
RACIST AND EVERYONE FROM
EVERYWHERE IS THE SAME LEVEL OF
AWESOME?
FOR AN ANSWER, IGNORE WHAT THEY
SAY.
TAKE INSTEAD A CLOSE LOOK AT HOW
THEY LIVE.
TO OUR ELITES SEND THEIR OWN
CHILDREN TO COLLEGES WITH
UNIVERSAL ADMITTANCE POLICIES
WHERE EVERYBODY GETS IN?
STANFORD AND YALE.
PRECISELY BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
MOST SELECTIVE ONES.
HARVARD'S ACCEPTANCE RATE IS
ABOVE 5%.
THEY BRAG ABOUT HOW MANY HIGH
SCHOOL VALEDICTORIANS THEY
REJECT.
ADMIT POORLY EDUCATED HAITIANS
THAT CAN'T SPEAK ENGLISH?
NONE.
HARVARD IS FAMOUS AND ADMIRED
BECAUSE ITS SELECTIVE.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT DISCRIMINATES
ON ACHIEVEMENT AND ABILITY.
IF HARVARD CHOSE ITS STUDENTS
THE WAY AMERICA CHOSE ITS
IMMIGRANTS, OUR ELITES WOULDN'T
SEND THEIR KIDS THERE.
THE CACHE WOULD BE GONE ALONG
WITH THE QUALITY.
THE SAME GOES FOR CORPORATE
AMERICA.
DOES FACEBOOK HIRE BY A
DIVERSITY LOTTERY?
WOULD GOOGLE APPLY TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS TO ITS OWN WORK
FORCE?
HIRING AND KEEPING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE AT NO SKILLS BECAUSE
THEY'RE FROM IMPOVERISHED
BACKGROUND?
FACEBOOK CARE ABOUT THEIR
RUN HARVARD CARE ABOUT THEIR
SCHOOL.
THE ONE THING NONE OF THEM CARE
ABOUT IS AMERICA WHICH IS WHY
THEY'RE DEMANDING STANDARDS FOR
OUR COUNTRY THEY WOULD NEVER
APPLY TO THEMSELVES.
IT IS SICKENING AND HYPOCRITICAL
AND WE'VE HAD ENOUGH OF IT.
GOING FORWARD, WE'RE GOING TO
PUSH THIS COUNTRY'S ELITES TO
IF AMERICA MUST GIVE CITIZENSHIP
TO 11 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS, HARVARD SHOULD GIVEN
FREE TUITION TO UNDOCUMENTED
SERVICES IN YOUR CITY, WHY IS IT
WRONG TO LIVE IN A DORM AT
NOR THE IMMIGRANTS.
THE TRUTH IS, A RULING CLASS
CROWDED EMERGENCY ROOMS OR
SENDING THEIR KIDS TO CHAOTIC
PUBLIC SCHOOLS OR COMPETING FOR
JOBS FOR PEOPLE THAT WORK LESS
THAN THEY WILL.
FOR THEM, OPEN BORDERS MEAN
CHEAPER LABOR AND BOUNTIFUL
HOUSEHOLD HELP.
UNLIKE YOU'RE, THEY SAY THEY'RE
GOOD PEOPLE.
THEY CARE.
WHAT A RULER'S NEED IS A STRONG
DOSE OF REALITY.
A SENSE OF WHAT THEIR POLICIES
MEAN FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
SO LET'S GIVE THEM THAT.
YOU CAN SEND YOUR IDEAS TO US ON
TWITTER.
YOU CAN SEND YOUR TWEET TO AT
TUCKER CARLSON.
HE'S AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT AND AN
ATTORNEY IN NEW YORK.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> HAPPY NEW YEAR.
>> Tucker: HAPPY NEW YEAR.
WHY NOT TREAT AMERICA LIKE YOU
REALLY CARED ABOUT IT?
POLICY MAKERS TWEET IT WITH HALF
THE CARE THAT HARVARD TREATS ITS
SCHOOLS WITH AND FIGURE OUT
IT'S NOT ABOUT RACE BUT THE
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF DATA THAT WE
HAVE WHEN PEOPLE GET HER AND
PEOPLE THAT ARE MORE LIKELY TO
SUCCEED GET PREFERENCE AND THOSE
THAT WON'T WON'T.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THAT?
>> THE FIRST POINT IS THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS NOT A COMPANY.
THE UNITED STATES IS NOT A
SCHOOL.
IT'S A NATION.
SECOND POINT, WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE SCRUTINIZE EVERY
PERSON COMING HERE INTO THE
COUNTRY.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY TERRORIST BACKING
OR A VIOLENT RECORD.
BUT THE UNITED NATIONS WAS
CREATED IN THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE BECAUSE THE KING
RESTRICTED IMMIGRATION.
BECAUSE THE KING OF ENGLAND SAID
STATES, COLONIES, YOU CAN NO
LONGER BRING PEOPLE FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES --
>> Tucker: WHO TOLD YOU --
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT --
>> Tucker: THIS IS NOT ABOUT
KING GEORGE.
OKAY.
THAT'S A WHOLE OTHER SHOW.
LET'S JUST BACK UP A LITTLE BIT.
YOU SAID THE TWO STANDARDS WE
NEED TO APPLY ARE PEOPLE ARE NOT
TERRORISTS AND THEY DON'T HAVE A
CRIMINAL RECORD.
WOULD YOU APPLY THOSE STANDARDS
IN YOUR OWN LIFE TO ANYTHING?
I'M GOING TO HIRE THIS PERSON,
LET THEM INTO MY SCHOOL, I'LL
MARRY THIS PERSON.
JUST AS LONG AS THIS PERSON
DOESN'T HAVE A TERROR BACKGROUND
OR A CRIMINAL BACKGROUND.
SHOULDN'T WE AIM HIGHER THAN
THAT IF WE CARED ABOUT THE
COUNTRY?
>> OF COURSE.
WE WANT STANDARDS.
AT THE SAME TIME, WHAT MADE THIS
GREAT NATION IS WHAT WE SEE IN
THE STATUE OF LIBERTY.
GIVE ME YOUR POOR, YOUR HUDDLED
MASSES.
YOUR ANCESTORS CAME WHEN THEY
WERE POOR.
MANY ANCESTORS OR THE FOUNDING
FATHERS CAME WHEN THEY WERE
POOR.
LOOK AT YOU NOW --
>> YOU'RE MISSING IT.
THIS IS NOT -- WE'RE NOT IN THE
18th CENTURY NOW.
IF YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT THE
COUNTRY, YOU THINK DEEPLY ABOUT
WHAT IS GOING TO MAKE IT BETTER
AND SAFER AND MORE PROSPEROUS,
HAPPY, COZISIVE.
YOU DON'T ADOPT A FAITH-BASED
DESCRIPTION AND ROLL WITH THAT.
YOU DON'T THAT.
YOU SAY FOR EXAMPLE -- I'LL
THE SCIENCE TALENT SEARCH
COMPETITION TRIES TO IDENTIFY
KIDS THAT ARE GOOD AT SCIENCE,
WHICH IS A GOOD MEASURE.
TESTING STUDENTS IN AMERICA.
14 OF THE TOP 40 HAVE INDIAN
IMMIGRANT PARENTS.
SO THAT WOULD SUGGEST, GEE WHIZ,
THAT AND A LOT OF MARKERS
SUGGEST THE INDIANS DO WELL.
WHAT DO ENCOURAGE MORE INDIAN
IMMIGRATION.
WHY WOULD THAT BE BAD?
>> WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
ATTRACT THE BEST, OBVIOUSLY BUT
WE WANT PEOPLE THAT HAVE A
BELIEF OF WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
COME HERE WORK HARD.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES THIS NATION
GREAT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN ABOUT PEOPLE
GIVE ME YOUR SCIENTISTS, GIVE ME
YOUR ENGINEERS.
>> Tucker: SO HOW ABOUT WE -- WE
SUCCESS OR INTELLIGENCE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
JUST HARD WORK.
SO YOU WOULDN'T BE AGAINST
SAYING IF YOU'RE HERE AS AN
IMMIGRANT, YOU TAKE NO PUBLIC
BENEFIT OF ANY KIND.
YOU CAN'T GO TO AN EMERGENCY
ROOM FOR HEALTHCARE.
YOU CAN'T USE EMERGENCY MEDICAID
FOR YOUR HEALTHCARE.
YOU CAN'T TAKE ANY PROGRAM AT
ALL, RIGHT?
WHY WOULD WE BRING PEOPLE HERE
AND GIVE THEM FREE STUFF.
WOULD YOU BE FOR THAT?
>> I AM FOR NO TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE NOT FOR THAT.
OH, OKAY.
HOW ABOUT THE HARD WORK PART?
>> THEY SHOULD GET PROTECT, THEY
SHOULD GET HEALTH CARE IF THEY
PAY FOR THEIR OWN DOCTOR OR
SECURITY --
>> Tucker: WOULD IT BE FAIR FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO OWN THIS COUNTRY,
WHICH IS THE VOTERS, THE
CITIZENS TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO
DO A REALLY SIMPLE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS ON EVERY IMMIGRANT.
ARE YOU PAYING IN MORE THAN
YOU'RE TAKING OUT.
IF YOU'RE NOT, YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE.
>> IN 2016, UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS --
>> Tucker: DON'T GIVE ME
GENIZATIONS
GENIZATION
GENERA
GENERALIZATIONS
GENERALIZATION
GENERALIZATIONS.
IN EACH SPECIFIC CASE, IF YOU'RE
AN IMMIGRANT, PROVE THAT YOU'RE
PRODUCING MORE THAN YOU'RE
CONSUME.
WOULD YOU BE FOR A FLYING THAT
STANDARD?
>> I'M FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
I'M FOR REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS
COMING TOGETHER --
>> Tucker: YOU'RE NOT FOR THAT
STANDARD.
SO --
>> WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER FOR A
SOLUTION.
I WANT STANDARDS THAT WORK FOR
THAT WORK FOR AMERICANS?
IT'S NO FOR EVERYBODY.
AMERICA DOESN'T EXIST TO HELP
THE POPULATIONS OF OTHER
OWN PEOPLE.
IT'S A DEMOCRACY, AS YOU KNOW.
WHY WOULDN'T THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE A RIGHT TO SAY WE'RE ONLY
ADMITTING PEOPLE THAT CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY MAKE THIS
COUNTRY BETTER?
NOT IN A GENERAL SENSE.
BUT LIKE A SPECIFIC MATHEMATICAL
SENSE.
WHAT WOULD BE WRONG WITH THAT?
>> THIS NATION IS A GREAT PLACE
BECAUSE WE HAVE ALLOWED THE
POOR, THE PEOPLE THAT ARE HUNGRY
BACK -- YOUR ANCESTORS WERE
PEER.
YOUR --
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT MY ANCESTORS.
MY POINT --
>> WE WANT THE FUTURE -- FOR ME,
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I'M HERE AS
>> Tucker: LET'S HAVE A
RATIONALE CONVERSATION.
YOU'RE CAPABLE OF -- LET ME ASK
YOU A SIMPLE QUESTION.
IF MORE IMMIGRATION MAKES THE
COUNTRY RICHER, WHY DOES THE
STATE WITH THE MOST IMMIGRATION,
WHICH IS CALIFORNIA, KEEP
GETTING POORER?
IT HAS MORE POVERTY THAN ANY
STATE.
ONE OUT OF EVERY FIVE CALIFORNIA
ONE OUT OF EVERY FIVE CALIFORN A
CALIFORNIANS IS POOR.
HAS A SURPLUS OF MORE THAN $10
BILLION INTO THEIR STATE
ECONOMY.
WHY?
BECAUSE MANY FACTORS.
IT'S A WELCOMING STATE.
CALIFORNIA --
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND.
WAIT.
CALIFORNIA HAS GOTTEN -- HOLD
ON.
CALIFORNIA IS POORER -- ONE IN
CALIFORNIANS IS POOR.
THAT WASN'T THE CASE WHEN I GREW
WHY IS THE OPPOSITE HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA?
IT'S A SIMPLE QUESTION.
>> WELL, I THINK THERE'S MANY
FACTORS.
I DON'T THINK IT HAS TO DO WITH
IMMIGRATION.
IT HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE TO MANAGE BUDGETS RIGHT.
>> Tucker: OH, THEY HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE -- CALIFORNIA IS
NOW POORER THAN MISSISSIPPI.
IMMIGRATION, WHICH IS THE MAIN
THING THAT SEPARATES CALIFORNIA
AND MISSISSIPPI.
YOU HAVE DATA ON THAT OR YOU
DON'T WANT TO ADMIT IT?
IMMIGRANTS --
>> Tucker: WE'RE GIVING THEM
CREDIT FOR SUCCESS.
HERE'S THE STATE WITH THE MOST
IMMIGRANTS.
WHY IS IT THE POOR ESTATE?
>> CALIFORNIA HAS A SURPLUS.
THE ECONOMY IS DOING WELL.
WHY?
BECAUSE OF TIM GRANTS.
BECAUSE I WOULD SAY THE
IMMIGRANTS -- CALIFORNIA IS
DOING GREAT BECAUSE OF
IMMIGRANTS.
MANY FACTORS INTO PLAY.
AT THE END OF THE DAY --
>> Tucker: IT'S DOING SO WELL
IT'S THE POOR ESTATE.
THINGS ARE CHANGING FAST IN THIS
COUNTRY AND WE CARE ABOUT OUR
COUNTRY.
WE WANT IT TO BE THE BEST.
THE POINT IS TO PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE.